a little while back i started playing
around with the wombo ai art generator
and after putting in my name seeing what
came up with that i started playing
around with important documents from my
educational career and so i started with
my
honors thesis from my bachelor's and
then my master's thesis and the only one
that i haven't done a video about yet is
my dissertation and so that's what i
thought i would do as the last one
now
you can't put in very very long titles
and my dissertation actually does have a
very very long title namely catholicism
modernism and modernity the concrete
logic the philosophy of insufficiency
and the option in maurice blondel's le
ponce and le elezette so that's probably
about more than twice as long as you can
put in so i put in catholicism modernism
and modernity the concrete logic comma
the philosophy of insufficiency and i
left it at that just to see what it
would generate and i got some pretty
cool stuff
so i'm going to talk first about the one
that i like the best which is this one
right here and you see it's it's a
pretty cool image and why do i like this
one the best none of the images really
in my view captured what my dissertation
was about and
wombo just kind of ran with the
catholicism and modernity i don't know
if it drew in anything else maybe the
word philosophy or concrete or something
like that but this is a i actually like
this one quite a lot i mean it's it's
very dynamic you've got a number of
different levels to it it's a busy image
but there's that cool central focus
there on the yellow
whatever it is up in the corner so if we
look at this from that point on right
we've got this really cool sort of
sun-like image we move down into these
arches and there's people there
doing something enjoying themselves out
on these walks in this interesting
complex city that becomes more and more
peopled as we get to the bottom of it
and if we zoom in on the people
themselves you can see that
you know as opposed to a lot of wombo
images these are and remain pretty
people like
so some of them still do seem to have
faces
now this second one is my least favorite
one it's rather steam punky
it just doesn't come across that well
for me and if we start looking at it
from the bottom to the top so it's got
some pretty cool intricate
drawing like stuff of
maybe city stuff
windows there's looks like there's a
face in there we ascend and now we get
to something that at least looked like a
face at first and now it looks more like
a tumor or something like that
growth just kind of sticking out into
more of the city that's going up then we
ascend into the clouds and there's a bit
more things there and not not my
favorite uh probably my least favorite
moving on we've got a really cool image
here that
appears to have some script mixed in
with a rather idealized looping set of
images around a single
monastic looking figure if we zero in on
that we can see that it could be
anything but they they appear to have
some like a rainbow mask on and if we
zoom in on the uh writing we notice it's
not actually writing at all as a matter
of fact it's just blotches and maybe
these are supposed to be windows or
something like that it's almost like a
punch card really uh the next one is
pretty similar to the one that preceded
it except that we've got this weird
stylized cross in there which i'm
guessing came from the catholicism bit
and a bit more of the writing lee kind
of stuff and again a single figure who
is just there so if we start at the
bottom and ascend we notice we've got
again not writing and we move into this
interesting hooded figure that has
something coming out of its face or or
the background is flowing into it and
then we've got this cross here as well
and we move upward into
what is it you know a cityscape perhaps
things fading into the distance and
that's basically it for this one this
next one has what's definitely a cross
and two tiers of what appear to be
figures two figures at the bottom
standing on this again perhaps cityscape
and then we have another tier above with
somebody else up there now if we zoom in
and we begin heading downward we notice
that top one doesn't look like a person
at all it's at best you know an r2d2
droid or perhaps even a walking hot dog
or penis but we go down to this other
thing and
you know maybe these are one figure
maybe these are two figures but there's
definitely a cross there that's kind of
cool and you know i like the background
part of it
this second one kind of similar to it
again a figure with a cross but there's
some other cool features going on here
so if we start at the top notice that
yellow loop with the blazing
what is it a dot an i something in the
middle on the rather baroque
settings we
scroll down and we see
two figures here
a white one and a
reddish bluish blackish one that
actually seems to have hair
and pretty cool
flooring that might be reflecting a lot
of stuff
if we zoom in
and we go from the figure to this uh
central thing we get a little surprise
because maybe that's not actually an eye
maybe that's an illuminated face right
there that looks like another figure
doesn't it then here's one with a lot of
people or things
people like things in it and a lot going
on in different places sort of ascending
into the clouds and majesty so if we
start at the bottom which is the natural
place to begin we have what's maybe a
parent and a child um and we start
moving up we see more and more
people-like things all
you know pretty amorphous kind of
deformed a whole crowd of them here and
we start moving into the heavens and we
see something that's it could be angelic
figures blocking the way barring the way
maybe there's a table there and it leads
into this very cool movement into the
the heavens right now here's one that
doesn't have any figures at all just
more or less architectural type of stuff
and i actually like this one i like the
color scheme i like the ways in which
the angles and curves fit together and
create a beautiful space if we begin at
the top we can see that it's almost
there's almost like a stained
glassedness to this
but it's three-dimensional though
depicted in two dimensions right we
scroll down we see definite space here
there's there's some sort of stylized
symbol in white and you know we get to
the bottom of this loop and we've got a
floor that has some of the same sort of
pattern so we've got an enclosed space
this is probably this next one my second
favorite again no human figures or
human-like figures but there are a lot
of really cool geometric
patterns here this one's much more
organic you notice looking at the top
this almost looks like you know leaves
of
grass
woven into each other we go down we have
something that looks sort of like
symbols but aren't symbols we have
something that looks like it could be a
cross but isn't across and we go all the
way down to it where it gets darker and
darker into this beautiful end place
with no floor
now the next one is really quite
stark in many respects although the
patterning of the
you know sort of rose petal-like things
along with the tan bluish is
quite beautiful i think and if we look a
little bit closer we can see that it's
actually blobs of color floating into
each other and we've got this
interesting script-like thing again you
know wombo is great for creating things
that look like language that aren't
language and then we move up into
something that appears to be an
architectural feature or perhaps even
maybe it's a house maybe it's a church
maybe it's a domicile of some sort we're
not quite sure
what to make of it then uh we've got
this last one and uh i don't really know
what to make of this one it's you know
sort of past stylish a bunch of things
kind of blurred in together if we get a
little bit closer it looks almost
fabric like
as if fabric has been colored dyed and
then placed onto
a canvas that's partially been painted
on we scroll down we see more and more
of that something that could be a figure
maybe isn't one there's even things that
look like maybe hands in there there
doesn't seem to be any particular rhyme
or reason to it nothing that really
grabs the eye
so those are the latest in the
wombo generator again i applied this to
what i could input of my dissertation
title catholicism modernism and
modernity the concrete logic the
philosophy of insufficiency and the
option in maurice blondel's le ponce and
let's
obviously i could only put in like the
first hundred letters of that so not
quite the the whole thing but maybe
you'll find these interesting maybe you
want to experiment with it yourself and
there you have it
you